Vinnie so NAC natural asset companies
this is something that they were talking
about at World economic Forum what can
you tell us about NAC so uh I got a
message from uh a guy this how sick and
dope uh man is he was like Vinnie you
guys need to talk about this nobody is
talking about it I you know I want to
have this Farmland he messages you on he
messages me on the and today apparent I
think today is the the last day that you
can actually go out there on the public
record and try to fight uh fight this
thing so I'm going to go really fast uh
uh his name is Reginal let me find this
guy really really quick give me two
seconds uh Reggie okay here he goes so
he he messages me and says Vinnie I'm
sending you this minut uh in regarding
something about called natural asset
companies we have a chance to leave a
public comment opposing a mon Monet uh
monetizing of Natural Resources it ends
tomorrow which is today so this this
thing allows everything from the land
the air animals plants minerals to be
traded on the N uh New York City stock
exchange and monetized is creating
something called assets class of
billionaire oligarchs and he's he's
concerned because you know his kids you
know he wants his kids to be able to
hunt and do the stuff on the land so um
it's connected it's connected to the
world economic Forum it's a desire to to
create this class uh gobbling up our
public lands and waterways and
opportunity for public comment and
today's the last day and I I I'll send
Rob the link uh but there's a new uh
phrase called EOS side I don't know if
you've heard this or EOS side which is
actually elal side which is allowing
unelected Elites to tell Farmers to stop
farming I mean this is their goal we
know what they're doing we know what
China's buying up all this land Bill
Gates is one of these what one okay
let's let's stay on that so let's let's
Define eco side so Eco side it's it's
it's letting uh they want Farmers to
stop farming Fishers to stop fishing
Miners to stop Mining and when you allow
those things to happen this is what you
starve and unrest starts to happen the
so uh Society starts to collapse I have
a video I sent Rob uh Greta th thunberg
and her friend uh the CEO of stop
ecosite International her name is JoJo
meta demanded during the world economic
Forum on Tuesday uh that they dubbed
where nature meets conflict on Tuesday
it's a new international criminal
category of ecos side to prevent the
mass damage so they don't want you
fishing they don't want you doing
anything and they want people to be able
to trade and invest on your land even if
you own it and this is what her attit
this is just her attitude on fishing and
stuff uh this is ADD World economic this
world economic for okay go ahead I mean
EOS side as a word is becoming more it's
becoming better known around the world
and the concept is generally Mass damage
and destruction of nature um but legally
speaking um what our organization and
other collaborators aim to do is to have
this recognized legally as a serious
crime because one of the issues that
sort of pervades all of this discussion
is that we have a kind of cultural very
grained habit of not taking damage to
Nature as seriously as we take damage to
people and property um and that I mean
you know if you're campaigning for human
rights at least you know mass murder
torture all of these things are serious
crimes but there's no equivalent in the
environmental space um and so and and
you know unlike a an international crime
like genocide that in involves a
specific intent with ecocide what we see
is actually what people are trying to do
what businesses are trying to do is make
money is you know is Farm is fish is do
all of these things that are um you know
producing energy and so on um as well
but what's it what's missing is the
awareness and the conscience around the
side effects around the collateral
damage that happens with that yeah
fishing fishing and stuff on your own
land they want to and so Robert Robert
sent me this so basically they can rule
private property laws under the guys of
protecting the environment they can
basically control and the dude they're
going to be trading air do you
understand like air water Tom what are
your thoughts on this uh I think this
needs to shake out a little bit there's
a little bit of inflammatory speech
going on both sides but what you
basically have is the greens are trying
to find more ways to impose their will
and if the EPA won't do it fast enough
if the Paris Accords won't do it fast
enough they're trying to find other ways
to do it and what you heard her say is
she was equating and basically what
she's talking about is strip mining
where you go for coal and you dig those
big pits with all the levels you can see
which are pretty devastating right
because a lot of that runoff ends up in
streams which is bad so there's
something that's bad she's trying to
equate that with genocide and to put a
criminal penalty on it that's her that's
one of that's one of those angles and so
they're trying to find new ways to
invoke an environmentalist and uh green
agenda is what they're trying to do and
we should learn about this understand it
has a little bit of traction but also
has a hell of a lot of resistance right
now and the resist resistance is correct
and I sent Rob I sent Rob the link for
people to get on the sec.gov to to file
your your your your grievance and say no
they need comments to make this not
happen because this is horrible if this
goes through it's not going to be good
uh Adam yeah I don't this is the first
time hearing this so respect to you at
this here's what I will know and I'll
give a shout out to our friend
Constantine kiss from trigonometry I
remember when he got up on there in
Oxford and lectured the
global uh disaster the climate crisis
crowd who basically think the world is
coming to an end he said listen you have
to understand here in the UK we have the
luxury of having such a great life that
we can worry about all the problems that
don't actually exist right now but
everything that's going on in the
climate it's going to be solved if it
ever is in the poor countries and the in
the highly populated cor poor countries
like China India Latin America Brazil
because they're putting out the biggest
forms of uh pollution in the world but
you think that a poor Indian is waking
up living in the slums of Mumbai and
being like huh that global warming thing
dude they're trying to survive yep okay
so the poor people are the people that
are going to suffer the most by by this
type of agenda so they're looking on how
to pay the rent basically put some food
on the table and you're living in your
high-rise in New York or London worried
about the existential crisis that
doesn't really exist so it's all about
perspective people like to put all these
pictures out there of all the negative
that's happened I saw a very short
documentary on Chernobyl and so
Chernobyl a terrible econ economic
disaster for the city and for the people
and a human disaster and then just an
environmental disaster but you know what
they look back 20 years after chobble
you know what happened there they took
satellite pictures and looked the
vegetation and things that had grown
back over it was amazing so it shows
that Earth and trees and shrubs and
everything that was there with whatever
rainfall it gets it grew back and it was
this massive like like little
microforest that had grown in after
after other words after man left all
this stuff grew and they still had this
horrible thing in the middle it's
radioactive yes true but you also know
that the Earth heals itself pretty quick
everything grew back and they said all
this vegetation here is creating a whole
lot of oxygen and we still have this ice
sorts in the middle but so all of this
thing they only want to show one side
you know we stripped mine and we did all
this they don't want to show replanting
the trees they don't want to show that
if you leave it alone for 20 years that
all of a sudden you get the equivalent
of forest that grows back what what was
this documentary called it was it was
about Chernobyl it was short it was
about 10 minutes long I think some of
these are the pictures that you see of
Chernobyl where you see incredible
growth now that doesn't change the fact
in the middle of it is this little
radioactive pit but it does show you how
that if we don't keep cutting the trees
down the trees grow back if we don't cut
the brush down the brush grows back the
the the best thing you said is the earth
finds a way to heal itself that's why
it's called Mother Nature because women
grow life oh my gosh okay we all have
mothers here guys you can find his
profile on Tinder he's in Swip right
he's right so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here